Hey, everyone, we are back in the second part of our game theory basics.
And what we're going to do here are some extensions of that simple form or normal form game that we saw in part one.
Let's go ahead and dive into it.
So again, we have player one, we have player two.
For some reason, player two's little tag is further down from his body.
I don't know what's going on there.
But what we have is a situation in which these two players have been, oh, cult doing something wrong and so they've been thrown in jail.
Now, what we see here is they have strategies of confess or stay silent.
So player one can confess.
Player two could also confess to the crime that they committed.
Player one could confess and player two could stay silent.
So maybe they were colluding and player two doesn't want to give away what they did.
They stay silent.
Player one says, no, I'm going to confess.
I don't feel right about it.
And then we could also flip those strategies for player one and players two.
This is what this type of game is.
What we're looking at is called a prisoner's dilemma.
This is a particular game between two capture players that illustrates why cooperation is difficult to maintain even when it's mutually beneficial.
Now, what this means, prisoner's dilemma doesn't just apply to people actually being put in jail.
It's actually looking at a situation in which we create suboptimal outcomes as our equilibrium.
So what we're going to be seeing here is what might look like a good choice for these players.
In reality, it's not a good choice.
So let's see what the penalty is going to be.
So minus 5,000 if they both confess.
So this could be $5,000, for example.
Now, if they.  If Player 2 confesses, Player 1 stays silent.
Player 1 now has to pay $10,000.
Player 2 only has to pay $1,000.
Now, if Player 1 confesses, Player 2 stays silent, then what we see is Player 1 only pays $1,000 and Player 2 pays 10,000.
Okay, now what happens if they both stay silent?
Then they Both only pay $1,500.
If we go ahead and add up the amounts, we can see that staying silent is the Pareto optimal outcome for these two players because that $3,000 that they would pay collectively is less than the 10,000 and 11,000 doll elsewhere.
But what we need to do is go in and figure out what they're actually going to do.
And so we want to use that little strategy that we developed in our previous video where we compared the payoffs top and bottom, left and right.
So let's start with player one.
5000 and 1000 sound a lot better than paying 10,000 and 1500.  So we can.
We can see player one has a dominant strategy to confess.
Player two compared the 5000 and the 1000 to the 10,000 and the 1500.
And again, we can see the dominant strategy is for player two to also confess.
So they both pursue their dominant strategies.
And what we find by doing that is that they both confess to the crime and they move to a suboptimal outcome.
In fact, this is what we call a Nash equilibrium.
This is when a player cannot unilaterally make a change in their strategy and be better off.
We found the equilibrium.  Confess, Confess.
It's our Nash equilibrium.
Okay, but look what happens if player one says, I want to deviate away from confessing and I want to move to staying silent.  Look what happens.
They're actually worse off by doing so.
They go from minus 5,000 to minus 10,000.
That unilateral change made them worse off.
If player two does the same thing, they say, you know what?
I don't want to confess anymore.
I want to stay silent.
That 5,000 is better than that, minus 10,000.
And what we see again is that unilateral change does not help the player.
So that means the Nash equilibrium of both players confessing is going to be a situation which they can't make a better move.
They have to stay at confess, confess.
Otherwise they're paying much, much.  How about that?
More than what they want to.
So Nash equilibria arise even when we have dominant strategies or when we don't have dominant strategies.
That's a really neat thing about the Nash equilibrium.
You don't have to have a dominant strategy for a Nash equilibrium to occur.
And I think I have a game that I'm going to show you how this works.
But now also notice what happens here.  I mentioned it earlier.
The Pareto optimal outcome disappears.
We don't choose it.
That is actually the best outcome for both players if they could both cooperate.
But in the classic dilemma, these two players are separated and they're interrogated differently.
So what we see is that these players can't cooperate.
They can't get the stay silent, stay silent.
So they rely on their own intuition, their own strategies.
And what we see is that they both confess.
So let's look at some more suboptimal outcomes, all right here.
Now we're choosing between raising price and lowering price.
And we're going to look at some payoffs here.
10 and 10 if they both choose to raise price, 12 and 0 if Player 1 lowers price and Player 2 raises price.
0 and 12 if Player 1 raises price and Player 2 lowers price.
And then 8 and 8, if they both choose to lower price, they look at 8 and 8.
Now, before we continue, just look at the combined payoffs and think to yourself, what is the Pareto optimal outcome?
And what do I think the outcome is going to be?
Again, what we have to do, compare the payoffs top, bottom, left and right.
And we see that the 10 and 0 oh, are not as good as the 12 and the 8.
Okay, so player one has a dominant strategy to do what?  Lower price.  All the time.
10 and 0 for player 2 is less than the 12 and 8 for player is less than the 12 and 8 in lowering the price.
So player 2 also has the dominant strategy to lower price.
But this is another sub optimal outcome.
They went based on their dominant strategies.
But we could do much, much better if we both chose to raise price.
The 10 and the 10 combined payoff of 20 is greater than the combined payoff of 16.
Also, the 10 is better than the 8.  So.
So in this case, we have a suboptimal outcome.
It's a Nash equilibrium.
We can't make ourselves any better by deviating.
If player one chooses to instead raise price, they go from 8 to 0.
The same thing for player two, they choose to raise price.
Instead of lowering price, they go from 8 to 0.
You can't make a unilateral change and make yourself better off.
So in this case, cooperation would be a great thing because they could have a much better outcome by doing so.
But in this case, they don't.
Let's move on to another one.
Now we're going to be looking at indifference in payoffs.
So what do we mean by this?
Well, we might have an outcome in which one player has the same payoff.
Let's look at what we get.
13 and 13 if they both choose to raise price, 9 if Player 1 lowers price, 10 if Player 2 raises price, 11 if Player 1 raises price.
And 14 if Player 2 lowers price.
And then 11 again if Player 1 lowers price, and Player 2 gets 12 for lowering their price.
So in this case, what are we going to do?
All right, let's look at the payoffs here.
13 versus 9.
So obviously 13 is better than 9, but 11 equals 11.
So it doesn't seem to be a clear dominant strategy for player one to necessarily raise price.
All right, so we're just Going to put one start.
We don't know what player.
If raise price, lower price is a good strategy yet for player one.
Player two, compare the 14 to 13.
Yeah, we see that that's better.
And compare the 12 to the 10.
And again, we see the 12 is better than 10.
So in this case, what we see, player two actually has a dominant strategy to always lower price.
But player one could go either way.
Now, the question then becomes, does player one, looking at player two strategies and payoff, does player one go, you know what?
I'm also going to choose lower.
Excuse me, choose raise price and give player two 14?
Or is player one going to go, you know what, I'm going to take 11 and lower price and give player two only 12.
What's that about?
This is a.
This is a credibility scenario.
In this case, if this is true competition, player one may actually choose to lower price, thus limiting the payoff that player two gets.
So when we have this indifference, we have to think about things like credibility is credibility is a credible threat.
Is one there?  Will it actually induce player two to go, you know what?
They're going to choose to lower price if I don't choose raise price.
So maybe I should choose to raise price, get 13, which is better than the 12, and take the hit by not getting the 14 that I want.
Now, now, it may be the case that player one decides to choose to raise price again.
Look, they make a unilateral decision.
They don't make themselves any better off, but they also don't make themselves any worse off.
So again, the idea of credibility comes into play here.
Will player one credibly commit to raising price or lowering price?
And that's some information that player two would want to get on player one.
All right, now, that is it for this particular video.
This, this, these basics.
So I hope you've enjoyed it.